Supergirl is about to make history.
During a San Diego Comic-Con panel on July
21st, 2018, the CW announced that Nicole Maines
will join Supergirl in Season 4 as Nia Nal,
aka Dreamer, the first transgender superhero
on television.
"It feels fitting to say that with great power
comes great responsibility."
Described by Deadline as "a soulful young
transgender woman with a fierce drive to protect
others," Nia reportedly won't start out as
a full-fledged vigilante.
Instead, the upcoming storyline will see Nia,
a new member of CatCo's reporting team, gradually
"fulfilling her destiny" to become the superhero
Dreamer.
"Nia is so much more than 'The Trans Superhero.'
She is a reporter, she is hopeful, she is
good."
Deadline speculates that the character's evolution
from Nia into Dreamer will be similar to the
way Melissa Benoist's Kara grew and matured
to become Supergirl as she stands today.
The character is a new iteration of DC Comics'
Nura Nal, aka Dream Girl, who made her comics
debut in 1964 and was given the codename "Dreamer"
in one '90s storyline.
Nicole Maines made national headlines when
she was just a young teen.
After the grandfather of a classmate at Maines'
elementary school in Orono, Maine complained
to school officials that Maines shouldn't
be allowed to use the girls' restroom - and
the school agreed - the Maines family sued
her school district.
In June of 2014, the Maine Supreme Judicial
Court found that the school district was in
violation of the Human Rights Act, and ruled
that trans students should be allowed to use
the restroom assigned to the gender with which
they identify.
Since then, Maines has been an outspoken activist
for the LGBTQ community.
In 2015, Maines and her family were the subject
of Washington Post writer Amy Ellis Nutt's
book Becoming Nicole: The Extraordinary Transformation
of an Ordinary Family, which chronicles the
Maines family's journey to better understand
and celebrate their daughter's identity.
That same year, Maines made her television
debut in an episode of USA Network's Royal
Pains, portraying a trans teen and choreographer
named Anna whose hormones posed a potential
risk to her heath.
In 2016, Maines was featured in HBO's The
Trans List, a documentary directed by Timothy
Greenfield-Sanders that highlights the stories
of 11 transgender individuals including Caitlyn
Jenner and Orange Is the New Black actress
Laverne Cox.
More recently, Maines spoke out about Scarlett
Johansson's involvement in the film Rub and
Tug.
Johansson was set to portray transgender gangster
and massage parlor owner Dante "Tex" Gill,
but dropped out of the project due to subsequent
backlash.
Maines told Variety,
"With trans folks, we have a lot of people
accusing us of just playing dress up for whatever
reason, and that's not true.
And so having trans people play trans roles
shows that we are valid in our identity and
we deserve to exist as we do."
It's for this reason that Maines' involvement
in Supergirl is not just exciting but also
incredibly important.
And Maines isn't the only new addition to
Supergirl's fourth season.
April Parker Jones is set to play Colonel
Haley, described by Deadline as a "hardline
career military woman" fiercely dedicated
to her country and loyal to a fault to her
commanding officers.
David Ajala is also on board as the devilishly
charming and witty antihero Manchester Black.
Supergirl introducing Maines' Nia Nal as TV's
first transgender superhero sets an incredible
precedent and opens the doors for even more
positive LGBTQ representation on the small
screen.
Will we see Alysia Yeoh, Batgirl's best friend,
roommate, and a transgender woman - in a DC
series in the future?
The Batgirl comic even featured Yeoh getting
married in 2015, marking the first transgender
wedding in mainstream comic book history.
For now, we can look forward to seeing Maines
team up with the rest of the Supergirl crew
when Season 4 premieres October 14th on the
CW.